hey guys welcome back to brewing you'll
be to Rebecca on apex legends again and
finally as of today they just released
the trailer for the battle paths for
season one that's gonna be coming out
tomorrow and I don't know if this is
actually real info or if this was leaked
from somewhere else because it
definitely wasn't from the developer
Twitter but it's also showing us some of
the free rewards were going to be
getting in the last final tears of the
battle pass and what's going to be in
store so as always like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe for a new I covered the
informational side of Apex legends so if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
apex legends definite stay subscribe to
the channel and with that let's get
started with today's video so first up
is this little 8 second teaser and it
says what others called dangerous
legends called Tuesday season 1 wild
frontier coming to at 10 a.m. Pacific
time tomorrow so it's gonna be around 1
p.m. est for the people in the East
Coast I don't know anything else besides
out of the United States so I do
apologize what are we becoming 10 a.m.
Pacific and I'll let you watch the
trailer right now
so yeah that was the chair looks really
badass it is only eight seconds though
of course but from what I can tell it
looks like that Mirage and Wraith have
different skins so of course we are
gonna be eating some new type of
customization for all type of Legends on
top of that it looks like the havoc at
the end of the video I believe that's
the havoc is getting some type of
different legendary skin I thought this
was a whole new weapon but I do believe
that this is actually just the legendary
version of bee havoc will to get into a
little bit later and as well octane made
a little bit of appearance in the eight
second trailer so of course it but
wasn't already known before octane is
confirmed to be the first new Legend of
Apex legends for season 1 next up going
into a little bit more information I
just want to clarify that I don't know
if this was actually confirmed I'd
pretty sure this was confirmed
but this wasn't shown off of any of the
actual official apex Twitter accounts
this is from like the leaks in the news
ones on Twitter so will not be showing
these just in case of copyright issues
with respawn and apex legends in general
but I will leave links to what I'm
talking about in the description down
below if you want to see them for
yourself while watching the video first
up is gonna be the bundles that you're
gonna beginning for the battle past the
first one is gonna be 950 apex coin so
you will have to buy the $10 version and
that's gonna get you off the regular
standard battle patch you're gonna start
at level one and you'll of a lot more
and constantly to unlock exclusive
rewards or you can buy the bundle very
similar to fortnight where you get a
little bit of a jump start exactly the
same as the battle pass accepts of
starting at level 1 you start at level
25 so you're about a quarter of the way
there already but it's for an extra
little bit of coins it's two thousand
eight hundred apex coins now as you all
know with this battle pass there is
going to be a free and a paid version
the paid version is gonna probably have
some type of reward at least once per
level but with the free rewards if you
don't feel like paying for the apex
coins you will be getting five apex
packs a wild frontier legend skin I
believe for maybe all the heroes or
maybe it's just one hero I don't know
and on top of that you will be getting
18 wild frontiers that trackers I have
no clue what they are and no clue what
that means maybe there will be new stat
tracking or maybe something regarding
new places on the map I have no clue but
there's gonna be some new stat tracks
for your characters next up is gonna be
the apex battle pass for season one's
gonna be the last five ranks in terms of
what we're gonna beginning as the last
five ranks are for number 95 you're
gonna be getting some type of player
icon very similar to what you would be
getting at your level when you look at
your character so
if you're like level 60 it'll have that
little gold or silver little icon with
the level 60 or the number 60 at the top
of it you could put that on your little
banner this is very similar except this
has a little bit of a funky design has
some feathers has been claw marks and s
as level 95 basically stating to
everyone in the lobby that you are in
level 95 for season 1 at level 96 you're
gonna be getting some type of intro quip
for life line 97 is apex coins doesn't
say how much though but there will be
coins 98 is some type of banner frame 99
seems to be some type of legendary or
maybe a purple variant of the R 301
carbine and then level 100 the last one
is going to be the same thing is 95 with
a level 100 type of icon and a legendary
skin for the havoc which looks like some
type of ice wolf looking skins got a lot
of white some blues and blacks it looks
really sick personally to me I don't
really use the havoc I'm more of a
devotion guy but that's just me but the
skin still looks cool so definitely
gonna be getting that once I get the
chance
and that guy's was all the info that we
know about season 1 so far like I said
it will be going live at 10 a.m. Pt if
you're in like California the western
side of the United States or around 1
p.m. if you're in the eastern side new
jersey new york that type of area when
the update will goes live i will be
showing off the entire 100 tiers for the
battle path so if you do want to be kept
up to date with that don't we stay
subscribe to the channel and just be
wait until tomorrow i'll try to have the
video out as soon as possible but that
guy's gonna be the end of the bait se
hopefully you guys did enjoy if you did
let me know by leaving a comment liking
the video and subscribing for more apex
legends content really lets me know that
I'm helping you guys out my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping up on
screen in a bit if you want to check
those out and with that have a great
rest of your day and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]